[Music]
on today's show i talked to a woman who
probably doesn't want to have kids but
her husband does
talk to a woman whose daughter is eight
years old and
overweight and she wants to know how
does she talk to her daughter about her
health
we talked to a woman whose husband's an
alcoholic and she doesn't know what to
do next
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
yo yo yo this is john with the dr john
dolone's show
so glad you're here with us there's 17
trillion 411 podcasts and you picked
this one to give us
your time and your attention so i'm so
grateful that you're here
we're talking about mental health
relationships addiction all of it
whatever you can think of
whatever's going on in your hearts and
mind if you want to be on the show i'd
love
to talk with you i'd love to have you on
the show
we get calls from all over planet earth
but we're missing you
so give us a call at 1-844-693-3290
leave a message kelly will listen to it
and give you a call back
if she deems you worthy right it's
1-844-693-3291
or go to johndalone.com
show and fill out the form and it will
go to kelly and then we will have you on
the show
i hope you will fill it out i hope
you'll make a call hope you
and your partner will make a call
anybody you know and love will make a
call
love to have you on the show all right
let's go straight to the phones we're
going to talk to marie
in north carolina except that is not
north carolina that is new york city
said the former geography teacher
think god everybody i was in high school
classroom shaping hearts and minds at
one point
what's up marie how are you hi doctor
john i'm so excited to talk to you today
i'm excited to have you get excited i am
glad that you're in new york and not
north carolina because
i live i taught geography what an idiot
what an idiot
hey so what's up how can i help okay so
my husband and i we cannot agree about
having children
and a lot of it has to do with him being
in law enforcement
oof it has been a year or two for your
family hasn't it
yes it's been really hard yeah really
tough and i got law enforcement family
too it has been a
messy messy year all every feeling every
everything right
yep yep all right so tell me about these
fights you're having
okay so uh i'll give you a little bit of
background we've been married for six
years
i'm 30 he's on he's almost 40. um i grew
up
in a law enforcement family as well my
father my grandfather
my father was in an elite unit in this
in new york city and he was never home
um so i kind of grew up like with my mom
really struggling um doing a lot of
things alone
raising us alone watching her cry a lot
and now that i'm
older she always says that she feels
like she felt like a single mom she
there's three of us so she felt like
she's a single mom
raising three kids um so now that we're
older my husband has not been in law
enforcement our whole marriage
he got in when we were married for three
years uh
or two years i don't know he's been on
for four years now um
and we like like like we both knew we
wanted kids but we've never like i've
never felt precious to have them he's
never pressured me
but now i feel like i don't want to feel
like a single mom
and i feel like i don't want to raise my
children while my husband is working 12
hour shifts every day working overtime
barely getting two days off a week
coming home
stressed out and don't get me wrong he's
amazing like i
won the the prize with him like i really
did
but i mean like there's like his job is
stressful that's just the reality
and i don't want to be
not that i feel like he would do this
but i feel like it's a possibility like
i don't want to be a punching bag for
his emotions i
and then having having to take care of
kids and then having to give up my own
life
it's just it's just really frustrating
and he's getting to an age because he is
10 years older than me that he's like
all right like i'm ready for children
and i'm like all right well i'm really
not
and i don't and i don't really want to
do this by myself
and i that's what i see happening for me
is me doing it by myself
gotcha thank you for being brave
that's not an easy thing to say out loud
all the stuff you just said
yeah so you know this but i'm gonna say
it out loud okay
your husband's not your dad is he
oh no he's not but you carry a lot of
your dad around
in your backpack don't you way too much
honestly
way too much
it sounds like you are more at war with
your old man and this
job that stole your dad than you are
your husband is that fair
i think that's fair so you think
man you said he won the lottery he's a
great guy serving his community he loves
you like crazy
what have you seen in him that makes you
think he's going to disappear on you
nothing like dr john he's amazing
like he's an amazing person i
there he would be the best of freaking
dad
ever like he would be the best dad
he would be so hands-on he would
really take care of me but i am just so
like i'm so afraid and i just remember
like turning 18 and finding out that
like
my you know my dad had some infidelities
um you know like while he was obviously
where he's retired now my parents are
really great
and they worked they worked through
those infidelities they did
but i saw my mom cry so much
and i saw her do work through that alone
too mostly alone honestly and i just
i don't know i i love my husband he's
just like i said he's the freaking best
but
i feel like every anybody is capable of
anything
and i feel like any situation is capable
of pain
listen i'm laughing because i do not
know
a cop's kid who who
trusts anyone i really don't
nobody right hey when you go into a
restaurant do you sit with your back to
the
to the wall yes of course i am a yes i'm
a psycho i
know you're new hey listen you're not
psycho you're a cops kid
i'm the same way okay um
i'm meeting with a counselor now and
maybe two sessions ago
the guy was like this psychologist he
was like
who do you trust and i was like uh
oh man my wife and he's like
you had to think about that who else and
i was like
todd like listen
all of your fears and insecurities are
are earned okay they're all earned
you've
lived it and here's the thing about for
those of you who don't know growing up
in the home of a cop
every single day they leave
their spouse knows they may not come
home
and it becomes so routine that we forget
those traumas just add up and add up and
add up and add up
and as a as a kid like you just see
dad you know taking shining his shoes
and cleaning his gun and look at his
bulletproof vest and you see how tough
and big
and you know wonderful that all this
and the fact he might die today or the
next day or the next day
and so all like marie
all of your stuff is well earned and can
i also say this
your dad could be a really amazing guy
and have totally not shown up for you as
a as a kid
it can be both in and he may have made
some
major changes in his life because cops
in the 70s and 80s had
zero there was nothing about how to take
care of yourself at
home nothing you were you you were
you were on the clock here you're about
your community and your kids
and family were just something that you
know it was like a hobby right
yeah and a lot of cops now or especially
the older ones are realizing oh my gosh
i gave up
everything right but it can be both hand
so your dad could have really really
sucked growing up
and your mom may have done it all by
herself and she may have done it
really hard and sometimes not very well
yeah and there's probably probably part
of you that is afraid as much afraid of
your
husband turning into your dad as you are
turning into your mom is that fair 100
oh 100 okay i my dad like my parents
were my mom was so busy taking care of
the kids and my dad was so busy working
that the only attention i was the oldest
so the only attention we really got was
disciplinary
um especially for my dad so we knew when
dad was coming home from work we were
gonna get it like if we got bad grades
and
i and i don't want to be that kind of
family
so listen listen listen don't
just don't
and i wish it was it was harder than
that but it's not
just choose not to be because here's
what i know about you just by this phone
call you're gonna be a
incredible mom if you decide to have
kids
incredible mom
and based on what you've told me about
your husband you listen to this show
right
people call and tell me all kinds of
crazy things about their husband you
like yours
a lot i love my love mine he's the
freaking best
well everyone loves their husband you
like yours that's a whole lot
that's a whole other level right yep
mm-hmm it's true
y'all are going to be incredible parents
it will take both of you saying we are
not
we are committed together
to not replay the past
and when my guess is your mom was
quote unquote really busy with the kids
and your dad was quote-unquote really
busy with the work
my guess is if you really dug into that
they were really busy
staying out of each other's way yeah
they were probably
really busy not wanting to be connected
to each other for some reasons that you
may never know about
yeah and so while i want you to hold
their experience in your hand because it
is your experience too
and those feelings of neglect and
frustration and
that pres man my wife calls it sunday
afternoon dad
that cop presence that walks in the door
you
feel it and you can be in your room door
shut listening to old like
poison cds and that that guy walks in
the door you know he's there
right it's true it's just this weight
right
that's all true and anxiety
it is it is but it's earned anxiety your
brain remembers that
and it doesn't want to do that again so
when your husband looks at you and he's
like hey i'm joining the police force
you're like oh cool and then you went oh
no right exactly your heart took off
your stomach drops
and he calls and he's like i'm gonna be
late you're like okay that's cool
and then there's a part of your brain
that sets off an alarm that goes here we
go again
and suddenly new york's gonna be more
important than you and you watch the
news
and every day you're like oh he's not
coming home he's not coming home and
almost to the point when he comes home
it becomes a surprise
and then you lean on him a little bit
heavier and you start creating a new
world right i've been
there okay and i'm not married to a cop
i just live with one
right and so here's the thing you hold
that in one hand
and in the other hand you hold your
husband's hand really tight
and you'll say we're not doing this
we're gonna put this family first
we're going to put our marriage first
and then our kids
you're going to be an incredible cop and
you're going to teach our kids what
loving their community looks like what
service really looks like
even when it's hard and scary and
you're gonna show them what listening
looks like and what feelings look like
and what's saying hey i messed up or i'm
wrong or i'm scared looks like
you're gonna show your kids what really
digging in on mom looks like
like not in a bad way and like i said
that all weird
like what love looks like gross love
like kids like quit kissing in the
kitchen
right all of those things are a choice
and that's a that's a somebody in your
family is going to have to turn and face
the forest fire
and i think it's you does that mean you
have to have kids no
but i think that you want them you just
don't want to be your mom
and i think that you want him you just
don't want him to be your dad
and all of a sudden these variables are
starting to line up oh he's got your
dad's job and oh
you don't want to be a single mom and oh
gosh that sounds like my mom and ah
and here we go right
i think y'all can do it in fact i know
you can do it
i know you can
it's about being super intentional and
saying this stops with us
and we're gonna be the greatest parents
who have ever lived
i'm gonna give you a copy of my book
redefining anxiety
y'all can use it as a road map and i
want y'all to have true
real weird hard conversations about not
weird
but let's just be honest are we going to
do this kid thing or not and don't leave
it hanging out there
don't let it just stay untethered come
up with it say we're going to talk about
it right now we're going to make a
decision then we're going to wait five
months we're not going to bring it up
we're not going to discuss it
and we will agree to keep looping back
to it but let's don't let that hang over
our relationship because it's going to
start
like a little splinter and then it's
going to turn into a wound and the whole
thing's going to get infected it's going
to become a mess
have it out have that hard conversation
and if you decide to have kids number
one you're going to be great
number two decide you're going to be
great number three
be about making it happen so stay on the
line there marie and we're gonna get you
a copy of that book we'll send it to you
for free
thank you so much for your call let's go
to
let's talk to megan in kansas city
missouri megan what's going on
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my call i was really excited to chat
with kelly this morning but i guess i
can talk to you too
well played i see what you did there
i think i should probably be a little
nicer to you because i need some advice
i disagree
kelly's she's the brains behind this
show
so what's up how can i help so my
husband and i need some parenting advice
we are the parent to the sweetest
cutest smartest most tenacious funniest
fastest eight-year-old little girl
um and we have some concerns about her
weight okay
um so she's eight she on her growth
chart has really been pacing 60
for height 90 for weight for really her
entire life since she's been tracked
okay um and so we have some concerns
about her weight she's kind of starting
to outpace her height
throat growth and so we brought our
concerns to her pediatrician
and we had a candid conversation with
her without her around
and just said you know we're really kind
of concerned you know we have our own
family struggles with obesity
um and we've been on our own health
journey but we we want better for her
and so we have been referred to our
local children's hospital to a weight
management clinic
okay um and so here are my two questions
is this something that we should pursue
if so
how in the world do we have this an
age-appropriate conversation with an
eight-year-old
about her body in a really healthy
empowering way
we really do not want to hurt her in the
process of trying to help her
gotcha number one this one's hard and so
i appreciate your
trust here man and it's out man i can
hear it over the phone you love this kid
don't you
oh gosh and let's i just want to call
out at the beginning of this
call anything weight discussion is just
so sensitive and so i'm gonna just go
blaze right through the middle of this
okay
and if i don't say it the right way or
if i
will lean one where the please just know
my heart is with you
and your husband and this beautiful
beautiful daughter okay
um so anytime i i have this conversation
anything health related to a kid
especially someone who's like eight and
not 18.
i always want to know the percentiles
right which you gave me 60 to 90 and it
sounds like the 90
is increasing right you know it's
increasing by probably
two to three percent okay um you know i
mean she's it's not
exploding uh but it's not going in the
right direction right okay
so this is a hard question where did she
learn this
where was this where where so
um especially childhood obesity would
fall under a disordered eating
right whether it's a coping tool or
whether it's just
available or whether it's a combination
of 500 different factors
where does she learn this
either modeling or see it do you and
your husband have weight challenges like
walk me through you and your husband's
journey
yeah so um my pediatrician put me on my
first diet when i was five years old
um and so i've got a pretty interesting
history of my weight
um and so i was on a diet from five to
thirty i had bariatric surgery at 30.
hold on i don't want to say very
interesting i want to use the word
trauma
oh yeah for sure okay not just
interesting i don't want to minimize it
that's
hard five-year-olds should not be on
diets right
right right um and so i had bariatric
surgery at 30 i've maintained 100 pound
weight loss for the past six years
awesome
um my husband had bare extra surgery
about three years ago he's also
maintained 100 pound weight loss we have
about seven members of our extended
family who have had bariatric surgery
and who have all maintained about a
hundred pound weight loss for a
significant amount of time awesome so if
if there's an obesity gene i'm pretty
sure we have that okay
but we have in our family we don't
personally been in our family we've got
type 2 diabetes
and heart conditions and all of the
things
that go along with it so i would say she
probably learned it from us even though
i feel like i've been hyper vigilant on
her eating and on her exercise and in
her relationship with her body
and i feel like we're doing a lot of
really great things with her nutrition
and bodytalk and um
things like that like it's like we're
really regimen and we're still
struggling and she's still
really struggling here gotcha so is
the so when you talk about you've
maintained a hundred
pound weight number one high five to you
that's incredible
okay and i'm gonna i feel like i'm the
both and guy always right
so that's incredible and i've seen it
to where maintaining the hundred pound
weight loss becomes the new drug
and because the regimen and the
militantness becomes the new pathology
is that you guys or have you for those
of you don't know disorder eating is so
hard because like if you're addicted to
cocaine
you can just stop being around cocaine
you can't do that with food you've got
to make peace with it
right and that's a whole other level are
you
in a healthy place with food or is it
something that you've learned to control
through power i am very very very
regimented with my food i treat
i treat my relationship food with food i
almost feel like a food addiction
like i don't eat any form of sugar even
stevia
because one bite is not enough it's on
i mean i'm out yeah um and so i eat
three meals a day
no snacks i weigh and measure my food i
have to be regimented
because i live in a brain that says too
much is not enough and so i can hit a
slippery slope fast
yes um is your husband similar
no no he is way more balanced with it
than i am
okay and he's maintained his weight loss
okay
so you um did he have the same childhood
you had
no he really didn't no he didn't he
was i mean a fairly you know average
weight kid he really started gaining in
like high school and college
um and then he had brain cancer a couple
years ago and has an autoimmune disease
and because of the medicine that he
takes it caused some weight gain
and so that was a lot of the catalyst
behind it
okay have you ever met with a
psychologist or a counselor for any
extended period of time
oh i've gone for years okay
so when somebody tells me they've gone
for years and
the so the their their day-to-day life
is still
so controlled by
this narrative there's a gap there
what is that gap what do you think that
is
so we i've probably gotten pretty
consistently for three
maybe four years and we have unpacked a
lot of family history our family
trauma that i went through so we've
spent probably the first three years
impacting family trauma
and now have really spent the past
probably six months to a year
talking through my relationship with
food and really unpacking my
relationship with food and how i handle
it
okay so
there if if every single person in your
family
um i don't want to i can't i'm not a
medical doctor so i cannot
rule out any sort of
genetic disposition any sort of medical
conditions that you and your family have
okay
so you know about that your pediatrician
knows about your kid's pediatrician
knows about that okay
what i can tell you is kids absorb
and when i say absorb i mean they
inhale it it's the air they breathe they
inhale
home tension and they inhale
home peace in a really
weird way and it becomes them
in a really weird way and i don't know
enough to to
tell you about um weight and how that
works i just don't know enough
right but i will use something like adhd
if you have like you hear a lot about
that's a neurological condition it's
a genetic issue
it is only in the right context in the
right environments
right so in a particular brain i'm a
card-carrying member of that crew
so in a particular chaotic
or exhausted or power
or whatever childhood you want to wrap
your head around
my brain went to solve problems that way
right which then leads to all sorts of
anxiety issues and all sorts of this and
this is i try to sit still in a
classroom for eight hours and then hold
a job and all those other things right
and so it may be this is me just
spitballing here not medical advice
that your kid absorbs chaos tension
regiment power and
because of the series of of genes that
that she inherited her outlet becomes
x right as though minds is why right
it doesn't mean we're broken it means
our body's doing exactly what they were
designed to do
at some point that means that the focus
in your world
has got to shift and this is so so so
hard
has to shift away from fighting and
towards peace
and i'm so so happy to hear you are on
that journey
right the fact that a five-year-old was
put on a diet
for 25 years and nobody said hey is this
working
right what i mean that's such a
traumatic thing that was done to you and
i'm so so sorry that you experienced
that
i hate that for you hate it hate it hate
it
and my hope and dream is i'm very
similar
if i have one gummy candy dude i will
i'll eat everything right
and i also know i can do that sometimes
and it's gonna be all right nobody's
you know and i'm gonna be back on my
cycle so i've made peace with it right
and that's what i long long for you so
getting back to your daughter
eight-year-olds can't make peace
they don't they're eight right
is your physician worried about your
daughter's health is he scared for her
or is he
listening to your family history and
listening to your fear about your
daughter
he's the same to me okay
so when he said or she recommended that
to go to a clinic what does that mean is
that an outpatient clinic is she gonna
go live there for six months what is
that going to be
no what it is is we will meet with a
doctor
and a dietitian via zoom um and so she
did lab this morning they're gonna look
at her labs look at her medical history
do some genetic testing to see if she
has an obesity gene
um and then she so there is a
genetic predisposition right there is
that that actual gene i'm sure
yes i'm sure there is and she hasn't
been tested for it but i
if i was a betting woman i would bet
that she probably died i don't know
enough about obesity genes to know so i
trust you that there's there and so then
my guess is
just looking at epigenetics that a whole
host of people may have that gene
but given the right set of trauma and
circumstances and filling the blanket on
the blank then that sucker
right gets activated and here we go okay
yeah um and so we're gonna meet with
them we'll be paired with a
pediatric dietitian and then there are
also some peer groups that she will be a
part of and like meet with zoom well
they'll talk through like
um activity and what are some good food
choices
and things like that and kind of walk
her through that they also are doing a
research study
which is why they're going to do genetic
testing they're also doing a research
study
to track her and track kids in their
program through their adolescence
to see who has the gene how they respond
to treatment um and who doesn't how they
respond because i think that their
but from what they said there's a lot of
research on
prevention there's not a lot of research
on damage control when we're already
here
not a lot of research about how to get
out of here yeah
so can i ask you this question this is
gonna sound like an indicting question
it's not at all
how did your daughter get here it sounds
like you have a
really regimented home that wouldn't
have sugar and all the breads and all
the stuff in it
and yet somehow she still found herself
here
how did she is it just her body's
response to protein intake and
healthy saturated fat intake i mean how
does she can be
it can't be it can't be that i mean it
has to be us i mean there's times where
well i mean we probably eat out probably
twice a month
she gets ice cream a couple times a
month but there are times where
you know we're not as regimented i mean
for the most part we're probably 80
really regimented and 20 percent not and
so she
had to have gotten here because of us
where her environment like but megan
80 wouldn't get you here 80
would it would be a 20 like just using
the math
i want to stay in my lane here and i
don't know enough about the medical
but an 80 like we're living in an 80 20
life
in a normal circumstance would not
equate to
a 90 to 94 93 percentile
does that make sense yeah what's that
gap what am i missing
i i mean it's easily that we could not
have been
as regimented as we have been in
probably the past year and so
it could be that i mean it could be i
don't i wish i knew if i knew i would
have fixed this already
okay what i i want you to be really
careful about that language
that you just said okay any time
and you've lived this anytime somebody
becomes a project
or something to fix because they are
broken that becomes trauma for the rest
of their life
okay okay your daughter's just
i mean you love her so much i can hear
it right
here's the person i want you to love too
i want you to love you
you've accomplished so much but it feels
like you are still working
so so so hard
is that right bad eyes
after all of your success and turning
the corner
you still don't like you why is that
i don't know i think i feel like i have
to earn
and i have to prove myself and earn
that love and prove that i'm successful
yeah you don't got to earn nothing and
somebody told you that a lot of people
have told you that
so what you need you need to do is you
need to eat better what you need to do
is you need to lose some weight
and what you need to do is whatever and
for some of us
like we were told to achieve
academically we were told to achieve on
a ball field you were told to achieve
in a dinner table and that's bullcrap
i'm so sorry that happened to you
my mom used to tell me it'd be really
pretty um if i would lose weight
that was the cutest cutest one here
green eyed little girl
i'm so sorry i want to do this to my
daughter i know you know so much
i want so much better for her and here's
where you start
you start with your mirror okay
now there's some very practical things
that y'all are gonna have to work
through as a family
right her weight is her weight and her
challenges or her challenges
right you're gonna have to work that
practically
that she is gonna learn how to love
herself
by the most important gigantic model she
has in the world and that's you
she's going to learn how to love her
future partner she's going to learn how
to
love food she's going to learn how to
love laughing learn how to
do all things from you
and if you say you got to love yourself
she will not be able to
know cognitively but she will sense the
disconnect between what you're saying
and how you
look at yourself
okay that's not an indictment that is
i'm telling you that not to pile more
crap
on you because you do not need that i'm
telling you that to let you know
that your husband loves you your little
girl loves you
and the world is waiting on megan to
love megan
you don't gotta achieve nothing nothing
okay okay
and you've listened to the show long
enough i'll tell you the truth if i
think you're being an idiot i'll tell
you the truth
okay okay
now here's the hard reality your
daughter is
is somehow get she doesn't feed herself
she's somehow getting this stuff here
um she's absorbing this stuff and i
think
um i don't have any problem with any
sort of if
a medical doctor says hey we need to do
a clinic intake i'm in no position to
override a medical doctor
what i would love to see is and
hopefully it would be a part of this
protocol
i'd love to see some sort of family
counseling with the three of you
maybe starting with you and your husband
and then
moving over to include your daughter
okay because something i want to get
underneath this
the symptoms here underneath the eating
underneath the
um the physiology here
underneath that and say what do we
how can we
become a resource for one another of
peace
right not not weighing everything
you got you may have to do that that may
be the rest of your life i hope it's not
and i hope the counselor you're with
psychologist with is making peace with
not learning to get tougher right being
vulnerable
with um
and you've got to deal with the medical
stuff with your daughter i keep saying
that over and over
but here's the thing you all have to
model a different life
and if that works through if that begins
with her going to this
program great and if it doesn't great
how you tell her
is just that you love her
love love love love her one thing i tell
my kids all the time
they've got one job i've got one job and
that's me helping them be safe
i'll say what's my one job and they'll
roll their eyes back keep me safe
right um i want you to let your daughter
know that you love her
and that you want her to be so so so so
well and so healthy
and that you're working on being healthy
that daddy's still working on being
healthy
and you're gonna help her learn some new
tools and how she can be healthy
okay and you're gonna start from there
any sort of hiding or lying to a kid
they will absorb it they will make it
their fault
and they'll chase that down for the rest
of her life so you gotta tell her the
truth
okay okay but also parents can weaponize
that like it was done to you
right you know what i mean by that yeah
you'd be so pretty if
you'd be so pretty if you could just
loosen
that stops in your heart right you're
not gonna pass that one on right
never awesome so it becomes
i want to we want to have a healthy
family that is always able to run and
play and laugh
and get old and be able to hang out with
our dog whatever the thing is
right this is about building a beautiful
wonderful healthy life
not running from an ugly one okay
and let's make no mistake too your
daughter knows that she doesn't look
like other kids
is that fair that's totally fair yeah
so we're going to focus less on the
aesthetics less on beauty because she is
beautiful
and wonderful and spunky and fire but
we're going to focus less on that stuff
we're going to focus more on building
something beautiful okay
okay okay hey she's really lucky to have
you as her mom
thank you and that
knucklehead husband of yours is really
lucky to have you as his wife
thank you so much okay okay i'm so
grateful that you called megan thank you
so much
[Music]
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt
i've been helping folks 101 for years
but i wanted to create something that
everyone could use anywhere at any time
so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just
walking with you through your anxiety
alarms from start
to finish i'll guide you through a
breathing exercise and show you how to
lean in
listen and head towards healing it is
free
and it's for everyone you can download
this guided meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's take one more call let's
go to lana in
portland oregon lana what's going on
hi how are you doctor john we are
rocking and rolling how are you
i'm doing good thank you i'm a huge fan
of yours and i'm so thankful to be on
the show hey thank you so much for
calling and thank you for being fan
number four
this is pretty cool so what's up how can
i help
okay my question is how do i tell my
husband
i'm not okay with his drinking even if
he
if he's not aggressive or mean and
according to him bills are getting paid
so
everything seems okay but i'm not okay
with him
drinking what are you not okay with
not okay with him drinking yeah
i was a bad i asked that question dumb
what are the things about his drinking
you're not okay with
he is a functional alcoholic and he
admits that
so he drinks a lot um it's
three to five times a week
um and i just i really tried every
method i tried being okay with it i
really did
let me back up let me back up paint me a
picture of
the husband that you would like to see
versus the one you have
okay so i kind of have both of them
in one person okay so when he drinks he
comes home
we might fight a little bit and he's
like oh i just had a beer
no big deal i'm just tired
and he just lays he just not very
functional he just lays he sleeps a lot
how many drinks a day does he have a day
uh if it's a weekend it's gonna be a few
at least
he can get drunk i don't know i haven't
he doesn't really drink in front of me
he hides it kind of because he knows i
don't like it
but to call somebody an alcoholic that
means they are drinking to excess
to the point that it impairs their life
and so
what how much is he having four or five
six ten drinks a day
is he just grabbing a beer after work
every day like where is he
i think he's more like a beer grabbing a
beer after work but then the weekend
he gets drunk okay almost every weekend
and he says he calls himself an
alcoholic
okay sometimes it hasn't been a week
that
there hasn't been a week that he didn't
drink okay
so having a beer after work i would not
classify somebody as an alcoholic that
way
if they are getting wasted three or four
or five times a week
they are they are unable to complete
normal life tasks if it's getting in the
way if it's spending money that you guys
don't have
if it is yeah that's that's that that's
spending money we don't have
okay barely making ends meet
that's uh that's saying uh i'm
working on it it's gonna get better it
it's hiding beers for me it doesn't
he doesn't tell me how much he had
definitely does he have
you called about him and he's not on the
phone the only person i can talk about
is you okay yes
what is he hiding from
you i don't know atlanta do you like him
i do i love him you love him but
you love him yes i love a lot of people
i don't like him
do you like when he dreams i start i'm
starting to not like him
okay but you say he drinks every day
yeah
and i wonder if you've y'all have done a
dance long enough
to where you don't like him most days
and when he's not at work
and he's going to be around you all
weekend
he knows one way to disappear in broad
daylight
this is this is tough this is hard
oh now listen i i in no way shape form
or fashion am i excusing
him getting drunk all the time yeah i'm
never gonna say that it's your fault
that he's an alcoholic
i you haven't convinced me that he is an
alcoholic sounds like he drinks a lot
but more than that um it sounds like
y'all are living two parallel lives
stuck in the same house
you're talking to me like people talk
about their annoying roommate
[Applause]
because i think it's at the point where
i'm i'm annoyed with it i really try to
be okay with like okay he just drinks
but his health is in jeopardy his liver
is failing
he has a really fatty liver and
every time he goes to a doctor they keep
talking to him about it
and it's it's so scary honestly i
sometimes i feel like i'm gonna wake up
and he's gonna be dead next to me and
that that really
scares me and i'm not okay like okay so
how do you how do you feel
elena how do you tell him that okay i
my guess is my guess is i'll cut to the
chase here
my guess is that you were just
more vulnerable with me just now i'm
scared
i'm gonna wake up and he's gonna be dead
and
he is big and he's got health problems
and he smells sometimes but i love him
and i'm terrified he's gonna wake up
dead i feel like you were just more
vulnerable with me than you've been with
him in a long time
is that true it's true i tried telling
him but it kind of
brings a fight every time he just wants
me to be normal with this and
when i try to open up i can't
i honestly uh when he drinks i just
instantly close up it's like i get in my
bubble in my head
yeah i'm not okay with it and then there
are days when
everything's fine and we talk and we
laugh and i just
fall in love with him again i'm like
this is what i want
if he just didn't drink he would be
amazing he would be perfect
but but then i had to
oh i just i didn't have a three uh two
year old
and i don't want her to grow in this
environment honestly
how old are you we don't i'm 29. how old
is he
he's 35 35. okay so here's a couple of
things that you can do
and at this point you're gonna have to
you're quickly running up
on what i would call your or what moment
yes i'm already there okay so you're
there
so if you wanna have this um a
conversation
you're gonna have to be vulnerable and
you're gonna have to go first
and being vulnerable means you're gonna
have to open yourself up to rejection
and getting hurt
there is no other way around it you
cannot complain
whine manipulate punch
hide whatever your way to somebody's
heart
it is not real okay yeah that's true
the only way the only and i am a
six foot two 200 pound texas male okay
it pains me to say what i'm saying out
loud got it
yes the only way to truly be in
relationship with somebody to be
vulnerable with them
is to say i'm scared about this
whatever this happens to be the economy
our house my job in your case i'm scared
you're gonna wake up dead
and it is perfect for a guy not perfect
but it's
it's common for a guy to roll over be
like i'm gonna be fine
marathon you'll be better off if i was
birth
and that's when you hold this beautiful
face
and say i'm scared you're gonna die
yeah and some guys can't hear that i
couldn't hear that for a long long time
and so number one i'm gonna give you
like four or five things okay number one
never have this conversation when he's
been drinking can't hear it yes
right i tried it it doesn't work
number two know that his feelings are
part of the problem
he's covering something up and it may be
35 years old
maybe 30 years old it may be a
combination of things
it may be a whole host of traumas and
challenges and all kinds of things you
may not even know anything about
he may look at that little two-year-old
and just think
i remember how my dad was my mom was my
granddad was i'm never gonna live
whatever shame cycle he's in know that
feelings are part of the problem that's
what he's covering up
right so when you
go after him and his quote unquote
feelings with your feelings
know that you are bringing a gun to a
knife fight that's
that's the scary thing okay right um
try not to have blowups if you feel a
fight coming on
back out and say it out loud i'm not
gonna fight with you
i love you and i'm scared for you but
i'm not gonna fight with you not today
okay i think um
uh can i go yeah yeah go ahead i think
he was the first one he's the sweetest
person honestly yeah
he was the first one to say okay i'm not
gonna argue with you i'm not gonna
just um he was the first one to say and
when the fight is coming
he's the first one to not fight i wanna
just be like okay
now but you know it's now that i'm
bothered by it let me tell you
you know yeah and here's here's here's
what your addiction is
to being right
your addiction is to winning
[Music]
well he says i have problems too he he
tells me well you have problems too and
i'm not gonna give up on you
but you want to give up on me because
last night we had
i said i might leave honestly i'm at the
point where
either you go to rehab or i'm going to
leave and he doesn't want to hear that
so so so that that response of oh you're
going to give up on me
you're bailing on me that's that's
that's a manipulative gaslighting
response okay so
don't fall for that all right and at the
same time
don't be addicted to being right don't
be addicted to having fights don't be
addicted to attacking
right be in this to solve this
relationship challenge
be in this to be vulnerable and to be
open and let this guy know he's loved
and let him know that you are going to
draw a line
and then you're going to decide what
that line is here's what i want you to
do i want you to write him a letter
that way he can see it and read it and
get really pissed off
or get really vulnerable really scared
but he can go back to it and go back to
i want you to write a letter
not one that's like you keep and you
keep and you keep not that kind of
letter lana
i want it to be a letter that says dear
sweetest sweetest husband
i love you we have a baby
i want you to be around for a long long
time and i'm really scared that you're
not gonna be
you're not mean you're not unsafe you're
not abusive
but when you drink you disappear you
check out and i need you here
your daughter your son we all need you
here
and i'm worried about your health i'm
worried about your life
and i've got some things i got to work
on too because i'm addicted to being
right
and i'm addicted to the fight i'm
addicted to
trying to drag emotion out of you
kicking and screaming
and at some point y'all both have to
learn some new relationship tools
probably that neither have you learned
in your old
in the the relationships that were
modeled for you
and let him know that you're committed
to learning new ways to communicate
sounds like you got a great guy man
who's really struggling he's really
hiding
and it sounds like you're somebody who
is so passionate and loves him and loves
him and loves him
and you just want him to be loved and do
the right things
and then y'all just get in this toxic
dance and you're just burning a hole in
the carpet
pretty soon the house is gonna burn down
so write him a letter tell me you love
him
don't put your or what statement in this
letter but i want you to go get with
somebody
i want you to go meet with a local
counselor in your area if you don't have
a local counselor once you go to
betterhelp.com
and i want you to get online and find a
counselor who will meet with you
talk through some of your relationship
challenges
you learn some new skills so that you
can address him
and i want you to really think deeply
about your or what moment what comes
next
because nagging and fighting and clawing
and scratching aren't going to solve
this
vulnerability is the way forward but
there has come a line
when you're an abusive relationship
you're married to an addict
that you have to draw your wetland okay
i want you to get some professional help
with that
okay i'm so glad you called i can tell
you love him
and you want him so bad
he deserves to hear how much you love
him and how scared you are for his life
thank you so much for a call all right
as we wrap up today's show
um this really is like top two or three
favorite songs of all time i've saved it
here it is from the 1997 album color in
the shape
is the foo fighters greatest is the
greatest song of all time
it's my top yeah top one or two ever
long and it goes like this
hello i've waited here for you ever long
and tonight i throw myself into and out
of the red and out of her head she's
saying
come down and waste away with me down
with me and slow how you wanted it to be
i'm over my head and out of her head
she's saying
and i wonder when i sing along with you
if everything could ever be this real
forever and
if anything could ever be this good
again the only thing i'll ever ask of
you
you've got to promise not to stop when i
say when
she's saying this is the dr john
dolone's show